have you ever had a show or series where
you really really enjoyed and then
something came
like you enjoyed before and then you
learnt about the creator or the author
yeah absolutely and and has that like
affected your view
of the show at all absolutely [ __ ]
when what happened to the [ __ ] gironi
kenshin right
yeah or recently backstage happened yeah
[ __ ] yeah i was enjoying acting so much
i'm like this is one of the most unique
shonen jump experiences and then that
happened and i was like well [ __ ]
and i kind of don't want to read it
anymore yeah and people want to always
be like you know you should separate
them but it's so hard to
do that when you you really respect the
work especially
especially with ronnie kenshi because
like this is coming from a massive
veronica engineer
and i was like i can't read it anymore
no no it's it was one of my favorite
shonen manga and anime growing up and i
still have the volumes on my shelf
yeah it's just like gathering dusk now
because
it's it's hard as well because you
almost respect because you respect the
work so much
that came from the mind and you almost
respect like the thought process and the
creativity it came from
the person right it all came from a mind
i think what's disturbing is like
what all these such amazing ideas came
out of the same head that was like oh i
should i should you know collect this
not good stuff yeah because because like
really like
i remember i was really into act age as
well and then after the news came out
you kind of looked at some of the like
some some of the plot points of that age
where it's like like we look at
everything like
an older guy grooming this 15 year old
school girl to become like a
one of the best actresses of all time
and you're like it was cool
without that knowledge to just think hey
you know maybe you're just trying to
help her yeah
as like as like a actress you know it
was like but now you kind of see like
the underlying reason
why he chose that right now there's just
this underlying reason that just makes
you really uncomfortable i mean like i
can't shake the uncomfortable maybe
maybe that's a complete coincidence we
will never know
but just the fact that we can now make
that correlation it just makes it that
much more uncomfortable
exactly and then you see people on
twitter like but it was it legal though
like they're like what does it matter if
it's legal it doesn't matter like
i just don't want to support a pedophile
really just seeing the [ __ ] replies
to the twitter on that was just like oh
my god i hate this world so much oh yeah
yeah cause people clearly liked the show
who were like but but but it was only
one right it's like
it doesn't matter if there's only one
what do you mean if it's only one
like one is more than zero
there's only one murder you're
give me more credit than that yeah no i
i was so [ __ ] disappointed in that
i'm like why is it always the good shows
i would i wouldn't even care if it was
like the mediocre [ __ ] like gary swing
yeah it's like if it was like the
[ __ ] critter of ghazi's wing right
then i'll be like yeah what the [ __ ]
ever right
like i didn't even enjoy it to begin
with but why is it always the good show
that it happens it's always like the
most talented [ __ ] it's a shame it's a
shame it's a shame
stop it